[Musique]
emploi puisque notre pays euh il y a
beaucoup de richesses mais nous les
Congolais on n'en profite rien les
Congolais meurent de faim pourquoi ils
n'ont pas de ressources pourquoi ils
n'ont pas de ressources c'est parce que
ils sont mal payés il n a pas de travail
il y a rien au juste il y a rien ça me
fait mal moi je voudrais aussi migrer
aller en Europe que de vivre ici là où
il y a la misère les prochain président
celui qui viendra qui prendra la place
qu'il puisse vraiment travailler plus
sur la sécurité
l'éducation et améliorer la condition de
des personnels soignant comme on dit la
santé n'a pas de prix beaucoup plus
d'assurance sociale assurance maladie ce
genre d'avantage que pe basique que peut
avoir une
population
[Musique]
on a suffisamment été tué nous avons on
connu des affres de la la guerre et nous
attendons du nouveau président et de ce
régime de finir avec la guerre à l'Est
qui nous
préoccupe je sais pas ce qu'un président
africain peut faire pour son peuple
parce que chacun travaille pour soi
et personne ne travaille pour le peuple
c'est ma conviction je n'iraai pas
vootter ni un député ni tout ce monde
vont pour remplir leur poche et c'est
tout